bon là jamais rien trouvé paria pas à
même pas un vêtement les arias le dos
c'est un souvenir douloureux qui refait
surface
le souvenir de ce jour du 8 juillet 1988
quand sa fille marie ange elle
disparaissait
trente ans après les faits michel
fourniret avoue l'avoir tué
mais avant d'y croire le père de des
preuves moi j'attends que pour les reds
où ça fait pas fait ou est elle a eu
lieu la rencontre
fourniret mario ruel aux larmes les pour
faire ça qui est posée à l'habitude et
où il leur offre finalement déposé voilà
alors c'est autant de points qui quand
ils sont résolus à ce moment là je crois
que oui
marie-angèle à telle était l'une des
nombreuses victimes du tueur en série
michel fourniret avait pour habitude de
commettre ces meurtres accompagné de sa
femme monique olivier c'est ensemble
qu'ils s'installeront à saint cyr les
colons en 1987 dans le petit village
ils vivent dans cette maison juste en
face de la place principale de nouveaux
habitants plutôt discret c'était ans
convoyaient pas en fait moi je les
voyais venir chercher leur pain en
magasin et puis nous envient là on n'a
rien vu on s'est douté de rien on n'a
rien vu alors ça fait mal
trente ans plus tard l'ombre de michel
fourniret plane donc toujours sur saint
cyr les colons à village dans lequel les
habitants ne pas oublier non plus la
deuxième victime pour laquelle michel
fourniret a aussi avoué son meurtre
il s'agit de joanna parrish une
britannique qui était assistante dans un
lycée à auxerre
son corps avait été retrouvé en 1990
ce